INO'TONIGHT, AS  CONTINU
TRUMP'NDICTMENT,
WETATOHAHE RE
E OF TRUL CASE AGAINSTRM PRESID
DIVIDED COUNTRY, A
FOER  MOVIEE COME
ARNOLD SCHWARZENGE SCHWARZEGLK
DO YOU PREFER BEING CALL
>> IMA TO
MELL
EVERYTHING.U
SACRAMENTO, THEY CALL ME THEGOVL
Y CALL ME
WH>>BETWEE I THINK I'LL GO
OLTUTION SAID THAT A L TIN. NOT
RIGHT NOW.
R
I  THERE AAT CANEVERYONE
P, HE'S NOT OR HE'S
NOO R TOO THATCAUSE IT'SOWABOUT
RATHER THAN, WHOO
FOR?
>> YOU'RSA WOULD RUN
FOR PREST UT, BECAUSE IT-
I SEE IT SO CLEA H ELECTION.
MEAN, IT'SIKN
RUNNING FOR GOVERNOR ARE LOOKIN
THINGS T DCAN'T  D MAKES IT
'S
ABLL NEEDSPEOPLE CTH Y IT.OU'VE
AFTER THRRECTION ON
JAARY 6th, TAKE A LOOK.
WAS IN THE  RIGHT HERE IN S.
S  TCAPITOL.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS AAI
N IN HRYTH.
E  I HELEVANT AS AN OLD
TWEET. NIGHT O, ORS IN ZI SYMPA
, TOFAIR TO E KRYSTA, NAZI
Y. IT
COURSEDIENKE THREAEMOCRACY ANDWT
WITH MY THTY, TH WLI
TOEY WERMISLED.
DONALD TRUMP.YOU SAID HE'GO.E'N
NOMINATION.
>>OU WT KNOW T . PREDICTED THAT.
BUT WE WILL SEE.
ON.EMBER, THE FUTURE STIOES
EEA  RIGHT II CANNUTINK L BEI LL
N TRU H BEECT
PU WM
AGAINST THE SPECIAW  FIRST OF A,
THEN HE'S GOG IN DEEP
THE SAME TIME,  T
Y TH, INGUILTY.WEL
Y  FUTURE.HEREK P
FACT THAT HE COULD BE RE-ELEENT.
T YOU GEN'T THITTO H
LE OF THE
PE VG  Y
POLLS.
I THINK  A GREATL
NUMONGST C Y PL
TOGE ENOH.WIOTD
I BEEVOUE RISE OF N HE DO THAT
ANTI-SEMITISM IN THIS COUNTRY
AND AROUND THERE
ARE.
CCESSFUL MOVEMT D ON.
ME, THINK ABTHAT.
DO YOU THINK IT E IN THE U.S.
HATE, TO END?
MEDIA AND ONLINE OTHING SO MUCH
THEY FEEOUTHINGS.LEGATIVE,GAOW
SO WHA IS WA
TOL PEOPLE O OF THATNEGATIVISMK
TEHE
TELL THEM THEY'RE IN GOO
THAT THERE'S HELP FOR THEM ANDL.
I JUST- ERE S Y.
ANVEBEOPTIMIST.
I ALWAYS HAVEN POSITIVE
AND YES, T'S OTHI , BU E E THPE.
AND ABAL PROBLEM HAVE.
YOU KNOW, GAOPLE
KIND OSTUFF,MEXICANS, RUS AND
T VE COME .
IT DOESN'T MTE NO  THEY AR
TRY TO SEE THEIR P OF VIEWALSOEV
WOCE
U SAID YOU LIKE
NGE. THINK IT'S BA
MARKETING.
>> WELL, BECAUSE WHEN YO
GE, IT'S
SOMETHINATRRHING THAT IS
ALWAYS GO GRADLLPP.
AND PEOPLE'S MINDS - T G DOWN
SO TTAMETHING THAT IS REALLY CA.
THRYONE WILL GET ON BOARD.
BU YOU SAY, CHANGE,
REPUBLICANS STILL WILL
IMHE
NE
WORDAT
ACCORDING TO T HLT
ORGANITION, 7 MILLION PEOPLE A
YEAR DIEAUPOLLUT
YES, THERE'S MAYBE ADREDLE DYINR
BEODR , SO
NO POLLUTIONOULD T
POLLUTION.
THAT IS WHAT W
O  DAYS.E ST
POPULAESTFLIX.
FIRST, ," IN  CIA
OPERIVUTHED OU
R OPERATIV BE HIS DAUGHTER.
Y.
>> EMMA!
ALL OVER THE P
I CAN'T GET A SHOT OLE TO HIT ME
GOT FOMEE DELIGHT ISBE
>> RIGHT
KIEAT
THATT S SO WELL WRITTEN THAT
I D  MYSELF.
I COULD DO THEON, I COULD DOSERT
I ,  ALL D
LAYERST
THE WRITERS WERE ANDLYOB.THEYRO
TO GO VEEI V
THE IDEA OF RUHEPUEDOFF.
>> OKAY.
YOU'RE 75 YEOL G IN THE
WORLD.
?JNG
MOTIVATED BY ANYTHING THAT I'VE
DONE BECAUSE OF MONEY.
IT WAS AD, I LOVED BODY BUILDIN
I LOVED  MOVS,SCENES.
YES, YOU GO AND STARTT